[Music]
a lot of people have asked about our
office because we've seen videos and
actually has a pretty cool history we're
going to take two minutes to show you
where we work where we read emails every
day and where everyone thinks out so we
don't to go to my car but the brief
history behind this office is that
craigslist was started in 1996 Craig
Newark the guys start craigslist
actually lives tonight on the street
nearby and he started out of this office
and craigslist was actually here up
until like I think pretty recently where
they had like 50 employees working out
as a small house if it's a house the
technically zoned at an office so let's
put the street and go inside for all the
hippies out there nugs dotnet is located
vinitha if you have ever been to like a
grateful bit or DMV concerts like the
website for trading mixtape
[Music]
I've never been able to prove that
definitely was actually work here but
the sign has been here and you see
people on foursquare checked into the
original Zappos office at this location
no proof but we still get Craig's mail
on a regular basis okay first room in
here for lounge area he just hang out
and have meetings secondly look this
room's not very fancy okay sup days oh
there we go this is where all the magic
happens five smashed by magic I mean
this is where we pack t-shirts and send
it to our ambassadors so we keep all of
our flag hat huggies and whenever people
become ambassadors once a month we ship
them out it out of here and we thought
about turning this into a place to
record videos who knows that that we're
going to happen
okay here's the second Papa's room very
simple one of the best purposes of a
ten-dollar masking no-brainer got some
of our beaches after an awful tour so
then Scott eat up Russ Russ stop reader
here's our kitchen pack would put that
lets me to get at four pork rinds not
much covers right
here's one the workspaces okay we don't
actually have a maintenance room / said
there's the whole team here's how we
stay organized
okay so we've got one person and often
another person in Minnesota we'll just
wrap them this is where we pull them up
for video we can talk to him and it
looks like we've got a book club going
on as week the attention merchant is
what we're reading oh you look at a bold
so we first when we first started we
actually only had one room here we
slowly expanded and we didn't want to
buy death because we weren't sure what
was and was not going to fit we actually
made our own desk with the knife block
in pieces of wood they look Papa two
dollars but every time you moved we just
be able to chop the wood and repurposing
the slavery stages on the money and if
it was cool okay quick interruption
here's our writers room done or illicit
series walking the dog yeah I'm sick sob
got this little foam doughnut I want it
because I eat so many well I'm going to
beat you up her like that don't eat it
we'll do a water bottle game going cold
coffee old coffee Mansour so on oh all
your liquid and Michael patients this is
called my creation Kendall's news play
with supporters yeah this is our
editorial calendar we have a digital
backup don't worry but just helps us
visualize
a color-coded of course had contemplated
shame for failing to know so we don't
forget to take money and this room
that's the writers room and I think
that's it so just in the entire office
except for the bathroom but I'm going to
go use right now so we don't lose out of
that